lange zeit anderthalb jahre weil die
einzige frage kommt der neue band ins
kino oder kommt ins kino und jetzt ist
er da
das schicksal hat uns wieder zusammen
gestellt jetzt ist mein gegner mein
gegner ich habe gestern abend gesehen
und war doch angetan denn man sich
natürlich das was man von jedem bond
film erwarten kann auch von einem wert
von cary fukunaga gedreht ist der bisher
ja nicht mit großen aktion firmen
aufgefallen ist
und nur 0 7
aber es geht vor allen dingen darum
endgültig festzuzurren wert dieser band
eigentlich geworden ist in der
verkörperung von daniel krieg und da hat
sich doch eine ganze menge getan was man
unter anderem daran sieht wie er mit
frauen umgeht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum seit ich dich verraten wir haben
alle unsere geheimnisse
ans band ist im ruhestand das ist die
ausgangsposition er sitzt in jamaica auf
jamaica dass er gesagt segelt und alt
trägt wieder dieser herrlichen oliver
braun
shirts shorts und fängt große fische und
sein alter freund felix leiter als von
der cia versucht ihn aus diesem
ruhestand heraus zu holen weil ein
wissenschaftler verschwunden ist den sie
ganz ganz dringend wieder finden müssen
und die sie alleine nicht so genau weiß
wie sie das machen sein gleichzeitig
kommt aber auch eine agentin des ms 6
des ehemaligen arbeitgebers von bonn
nach dem ärger um an ihnen dasselbe
anliegen zu richten und diese frau
überragt dinge trade bei ich würde mal
sagen ungefähr um anderthalb kopf
und trägt eine wunderbare perücke
mit schöpfen und max und so und nimmt
ihn mit auf ihrem auf ihre vespa das ist
ein tolles bild und als sie bei ihm dann
im schlafzimmer steht und ihre perücke
abnimmt sagt er einen von diesem
ranzigen sprüchen die band immer so
drauf hatte früher als die frauen noch
bond-girl hießen und sagt das war jetzt
nicht da zwei sieger wartet aber dass
sie einst aus dass aus woraufhin sie ihm
einen derartigen mitleidigen blick
zuwirft dass man schon sieht diese ganze
szene ist eigentlich nur fürs archiv das
klar ist so war es mal so sind die
verhältnisse nicht mehr diese frau die
nun im rest des films ohne brücke zu
gange ist hat auch eine nummer nämlich
007 sie fest
band bei msx nachfolgt und in nichts
nachsteht sie haben eine doppelagentin
ein passender user
dass sie auf ihn geschossen haben eine
fantastische frau gespielt von lachern
annimmt und ich hatte gehofft dass das
vielleicht nachfolgerin wird von der
geprägt aber wir haben ja alle schon von
werbekunden gehört nein wand bleibt
keinen mann und so muss es dann
vielleicht auch sein aber in diesem film
gibt es eben eine figur 007 von rms
sechst und das ist
es gibt weitere frauen es gibt nämlich
eine die ganzen wahnsinnig auf mont girl
macht sind wir am anfang war entsetzt in
havanna sie sind zu spät
einer der hamas heißt sie und man würde
eigentlich wie in jedem film in dem sie
vorkommen denkt man acht könnten wir
bitte bisschen mehr von ihr sehen aber
leider wenn das fest vorbei ist
verabschiedet sie sich und auch band
aber sie landen im bett das ist auch
etwas was in früheren filmen bestimmt
passiert wäre aber jetzt in diesem leben
nicht mehr weil daniel craig spannt eben
nicht mehr die super 6 ist ist er
eben früher immer war und was so
ungeheuerlich ermüdend war jetzt ist er
ernst stattdessen hat mir geschichte das
wissen wir ja seit zwei vor also eine
familiengeschichte und er hat so eine
ahnung davon dass auch in ihm eine seele
schlummert die möglicherweise zu retten
sei und auch darum geht es in diesem dem
letzten james bond mit dengue craig sie
liebt dich immer noch wusstest du dass
das ist gar nicht
gehört sie zu den ich kenne sie
überhaupt nicht wenn ihr geheimnis ans
licht kommt
wird es dann tot an
es ist natürlich weiterhin großes
spektakel kino und nur für solche
menschen gemacht die auf diese art des
kinos mögen das gehört dazu wenn es
nicht dazu doof ist und das ist nicht
der fall also man kann
kann es guten gewissens gucken wer weiß
zu machen sucht allerdings wie das im
früheren waren es ja gewesen sein
sondern befand ihn nie lustig aber es
gibt ja viele menschen die fanden diese
ironisch und so
das ist eine eigenschaft die ist wand in
der verkörperung durch der hier kriegt
dann doch abhanden gekommen
[Musik]